you're from the bay
from the bay but you don't make the
music you're you're
a a jedi on the mic man i like to call
it certain rappers jedis and lyrically
you're special
um why why is it that when i hear your
music i don't necessarily hear the bay
area influence off the rip
um great question
um i grew up like
just bay area to the core you know i
mean white t-shirt blue jeans and nike's
just
three times crazy just listening to all
the bass [ __ ] mac mall
right and um
i think around the hyphy era right when
the hyphae area came
in i started traveling a lot okay like
with my parents my parents was like
heavy in the real estate game
and i tell people all the time i grew up
kind of opposite of how most of my
friends did so a lot of my friends
they had like struggling upbringings
when they was very young
i didn't right my parents kind of met
your parents too yeah my mom's in vegas
so they had [ __ ] going on cardinals won
that game by the way i told his dad
yeah but um they already had things
going on
so we was able to travel a lot so my
parents had homes in like atlantic city
las vegas and we would just move around
and i would notice like
a lot of the songs that i loved back
home
wasn't being played in these other areas
so i would
make friends in vegas and make friends
in atlantic city and make friends in
philly
and i would play these songs and they'd
be like what is this bro what's this
right you know what i'm saying and for a
minute i used to feel like
oh they don't like the beat or they
don't get it or they don't they think
it's
it's like a gimmick or something like
that but what it is is we
we live on like an island right so our
culture is
very just like independent and it's us
to the core
so a lot of people don't really know
about
pimp culture right you know what i mean
a lot of people don't really know about
bipping and you know i mean certain
things we do in the bay
so when we talk about these things in
the songs and in the lyrics the rest of
the world is like what's that like what
is he talking about like i don't get
what he's saying
because it's something they're not used
to seeing every day so when i started
making music
i started like writing from not like a i
perspective
i feel like a lot of artists where i'm
from right from my eye perspective like
i take the [ __ ] i do this i got the
whip i do this i try to rap from like a
wii perspective to where
anybody could see it so it's like i say
lines to where the bear get it it's like
uh
you think you're gonna get the pennies
if you make a paddock freeze i could
take a [ __ ] to applebee she won't be
mad at me
you know what i'm saying but it's
applebee's everywhere everybody wearing
paddocks yeah you know what i mean
everybody's spending money on girls get
that two for 20 at applebee's man you
know what i'm saying so it's just like
always try to speak from a perspective
of being from the bay but where the
world could identify with things i'm
saying within the music